hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast gold standards and innovative
processes for dendritic cell research in
immuno oncology I'm Judy O'Rourke of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's webcast is
presented by lab roots comm the leading
social media site for science
professionals and sponsored by Milton E
biotech Milton E biotech is a global
provider of products and services that
advanced biomedical research and
cellular therapy the company's
innovative tools support research at
every level from basic research to
translational research to clinical
application this integrated portfolio in
a scientists and clinicians to obtain
analyze and utilize the cell Milton E
biotechs
technologies covered techniques of
sample preparation cell isolation cell
sorting flow cytometry cell culture
molecular analysis and preclinical
imaging there more than 25 years of
expertise span research areas including
immunology stem cell biology
neuroscience and cancer and clinical
research areas like hematology graft
engineering and a phoresis
the company also offers comprehensive
scientific support consultation and
expert training to learn more about
Milton a biotech visit wwl-tv biotech
comm before we start there are a few
instructions this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CC button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment
answers are welcome - you can do this by
hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome on Jan John Eck PhD dr. John Eck
is an immunologist and serves as the
head of our D reagents and immunotherapy
at Milton E biotech GmbH since earning a
PhD in basic immunology from the
University of Cologne in Germany he has
worked for more than 15 years in the
field of dendritic cells focusing on
these specific functions of different
dendritic cells subsets during his PhD
thesis dr. Jonathan and functionally
characterized several blood dendritic
cell specific receptors this includes
BBC a1 2 3 & 4 which became a
state-of-the-art marker for human
dendritic cell subsets his subsequent
work on BBC a2 provided the basis for
the clinical development of the BBC a2
specific antibody for the Yuson
interferon alpha driven autoimmune
diseases which is now being tested under
his supervision in a Phase one clinical
trial his group at Milton E biotech
develops assays tools and reagents for
research and clinical skills separation
and analysis of dendritic cells B cells
and tumor reactive T cells I will now
turn the presentation over to dr. Emilio
Melandri who will give the presentation
hi Judy and thank you very much welcome
everybody yes this is a melanoma laundry
a mere covering for dr. andronik because
unfortunately yes all for the flu and
easier today but here the community's
voice so he will unveil two earlier
questions but he asked me to present the
presentation for the majority of the
time so as Judy said we are really happy
to collaborate with lab root
on this particular webinar and they they
are doing a good job in selecting great
topics and speakers so in the next 45
minutes we will go through with some of
the reasons for why the new evidence in
telepathic tools available at brought
back the DC therapy to the top of the
moon oncology preclinical and clinical
research so let me go to the next slide
as a company we have to assure your
disclaimer and for the revelatory status
of the product that we will probably
overview a little bit today you can
check in them in there and then without
further ado let's see the agenda for
this talk so we will start with a brief
overview on the role of the net exciting
alternative in cancer and then touch
into solution to some challenges that we
face during the production of cellular
products including logistic and
management ones we will then explore
some of the gold standard and most
innovative processes for preclinical and
relational studies investigating the see
potential as therapeutic tools and
finally summarize the main point
discussed so let's dive in and set the
stage for the dendritic cells and how
they fit in the immune oncology arena so
new immunotherapy approaches aim
exciting cancer about the expanding and
the other summarize some of the major
ones similar therapy is an old friend in
wound oncology and lately it has gained
momentum thanks to the commercialization
of first cellular product like Provenge
and the success of kalki approaches
these approaches based on exploiting
cells of the immune system
extry bone to boost the response against
cancer other approaches are based on
different molecules such as monoclonal
antibodies which include II and
checkpoint inhibitors such a kind and
other nonspecific simulators such as the
receptor agonist they can be injected
chemically and then there are some
critic piracy
cancer cells and induce apoptosis that
in turn provided two antigens and an
inflammatory environment that might aid
the immune system impatient and finally
is more molecules and inhibitors the
target intracellular pathways all
suppressives cell types that might have
tumorigenic properties now all these
they are very important mechanism and
new to that we have but in this talk
which focuses on cell therapy as this
kind of immunotherapy is
well-established and provides a great
potential moreover some of the features
that it makes it an attractive option
compared to some of the other for
example if you consider monoclonal
antibodies we can say that the majority
of these treatment requires a continuous
high dose of therapeutic drugs to be
given to the patient's while this is my
treat might be not the case for
immunotherapy with cellular products for
the cytokines which is known that they
might induce and avoid activities and
also including viruses may generate
specific responses against the virus
itself that can hinder the efficacy of
such treatment and small molecules can
rapidly dissolve and have limited lymph
nodes attention while on the other hand
handling cells ex-vivo might ensure a
more targeted approach and a fine-tuning
of the protocol and it also allowed to
use much less of the cytokines and the
other drugs that can be combined for
this treatment so if we have to think
about the the focus of the immune
oncology if the consumer in oncology
let's say the fight against two more in
this case and if you have to think about
that the first thing that we have to
consider is the tumor itself so tumor
are highly heterogeneous and unique
entities it has become clear the country
the multi-color disease which American
family agreed upon is the predisposition
lifestyle environmental influences and
age
generate and many other components and
this is why so far probably successful
treatment eluded our grasp so however
the recent surge of new treatment and
new tools is opening the path to more
effective treatment options
the next to consider is the character of
this story so in this case the dendritic
cells and in our case we can say that in
the research that often define
naturalist nature with adjuvant
due to their capacity to initiate novel
immune responses orchestrating both they
need inductive immune system to fight
pathogenic and tumor challenges and
finally we are also to think about the
subject of this story that is that this
therapy so clinical research in this
area has proven the safety profile of
the approaches and that is highly
tolerated so that the patient's standard
of life is not seriously affected
moreover almost all clinical trial
demonstrated a DC box in our immunogenic
and induced clinical response in some
patients does in the current scenario
with new drugs antibiotics options
coming up cell therapy and in particular
DC therapy are taking center stage
propelled by the new conduct for finding
in the immuno therapy field because if
we consider any kind of immunotherapy
I mean the final goal of any modality is
to induce a sustained and effective
response in the earth against the cancer
and so in a sort of way any of these
immunotherapies into modulate either
directly or indirectly business
functions because this is really at the
center of the regulation of immune
responses so I think really really
dendritic cells have been investigating
in preclinical and clinical settings and
for the past two decades trials have
established prefer principle for the net
excel-based approaches this include not
only solid but ultimately methodological
malignancies
and some of the main features of the
dendritic cell vaccine you can see them
here on the left side of the screen are
the safety profile of the treatment the
ability to influence not only the extent
but also the quality with the immune
response generated the compatibility
with other therapeutic options and the
fact that by now there are more
improvised protocol for the production
of cell vaccines and I will speak about
some of these later on in the
presentation and this one is just to
show that there have been lots of trial
many more indications and design data
showing here that you can see and
appreciate our dendritic cell have been
really look after in the research and
clinical research field in the past few
decades
so in this timeline we can a little bit
contextualized some of the findings that
propelled the translational research on
individuals since their discovery by
Ralph Steinman to the present time so
you can see how the discovery of method
to generate the he like cell from for
example monitored progenitors made
possible faster studies including
clinical trials that implemented our 314
micro base to investigate this live
action potential in the late nineties NJ
joining that is actually here with me
identified ability a molecule that allow
the characterization of coronary disease
and and subsets and development of
technologies to either ladies cells we
can also see out in do it excel expanded
to other Filipino dishes such as
tolerant induction and we can also
appreciate out as accompaniment a
biotech supported the advancement of the
field in translational setting
contributing with solution to a rich
dendritic cells including
next-generation GMP platform for the
production of several products since the
early stages of immunotherapy with enter
addiction so the accumulated evidence
led to the first ba approvals for SLR
therapy product it was prevented by the
end room and the promising clinical
outcomes as a therapy in the last years
triggered the interest of Pharma and
biotech that Excel
the development of dendritic cell
therapy here we can see our recently new
DC based approaches under study to
improve the efficacy of dendritic cell
vaccine for example by harnessing the
power of primary dendritic cells like in
the mind DC study that is led by
Professor ear under the breeze and the
probes multicenter study that has been
recently funded by the EU so new
technologies such as production platform
for cell factories alternative delivery
system for the antigen to the non vult
excels and adjuvant for the correct
activation of these cells are currently
tested in the field and all of these
will also generate powerful a new
therapeutic protocols the last so let's
now see some written on a different the
digital subset and challenges in
generation cellular product when it
comes to an immunotherapy
so in human three different subsystems
and redux cells can be identified in
peripheral blood deep as master
dendritic cells and two myeloid the new
D cell populations that can be
characterized further by the expression
of D 1 C or C D 141 marker moreover we
already introduced the possibility of
generating yes of generating the
dendritic cells from progenitor and in
this case we speak about monosaccharides
and Dudek cells or dendritic cells
derive from a multiple attic stem cell
progenitors
but i mean when we stick with analysis
will also speak of the very rare and
cell population and is one of the
trouble and problems
in studying and working within the RIT
Excel and that let's see what are also
the requirement for the dendritic cell
and cellular product production so as a
living dragon cellular product pose
several unique challenges
starting with for example a robust
reliable enrichment of this stands for
that probably is going to use an
instrument compatible current good
manufacturing practices and ways to load
antigens and correctly stimulate the
dendritic cells avoid for example
tolerant induction and the final product
need to retain the functional properties
in viability of the rich sound
and finally reproducible in standardized
analytical tools are needed to ensure
for example the productivity and
efficiency so in the next slide I'm
summarizing some of the challenges and
some of the solution that are available
for processing so you can see for
example we need limiting limiting
contamination we need to limit the
contamination and enabling scalability
of the process in a cost-effective way
and the secure track the extensive
documentation is needed for regulatory
bodies and so all these can be helped
and aided by a closed on automated
platform such as degree max prodigy of
which I was speaking a lot just one by
the way what other challenges linked to
requirement for Jim P grade ancillary
products
Culture Media for example as well that
we solve by providing a range of
research grade to gently greatly agents
including cytokines deprivation or for
antigen loading like the recently
recently launched melanoma select to
reduce the complexity of the submission
process of your study protocol to the
regulatory agencies for example so since
a clear Jim deregulation for raw
materials for cell dairy product
available we manufacture our cytokines
and antigens accordingly to the relevant
GMP guidelines this is in order to
comply as much as possible to the
requests coming from locally read from
local regulatory authorities so now I
will show you how we can solve partially
some of this problem and this is thanks
to our climax prodigy the Klingon
strategies and innovative platform for
cellular processing and is fully
equipped to enable the automated
generation of the sea vaccines for
translational research it allows the
original and generational for example
monitoring real excels with our P 14
system or the innovative a Richmond and
activation of blood drive natural
dendritic cells through the DB DC system
this platform is exploiting a disposable
shipping set that allow an
individualized processing of patient
material the tipping set include also a
chamber is allowed for optimal
processing of cells in a closed system
with an inbuilt sample pouches set for
integrated analysis of the cell product
different stages of the process
this include also a density gradient
separation cell washing and
interrogation before another labeling a
magnetically reaching the target cells
so the this machine actually contain all
the different instrument that you need
for the production of a cell therapeutic
product but the prodigy is also platform
the solve logistic problem in the
production cycle and distribution of
retinol product for example we can see
here that weekly if we compare a
production line setting that has strict
requirements in terms of expensive self
actually species and the world for that
is well trained in gentle procedures we
can switch to an divided based
production system in which the prodigy
is only one unit in these production
suit or room and these can be easily and
scalable so it could pass at the next
slide conceal to that the prodigy
allowance so if you think about how a
lot of productivity start these life in
a clinical business you can think of it
one prepaid one to trial with few
patients one researcher is going to
start this trial Anna might purchase the
prodigy and is the prodigy for the
production of the sell product and then
this trial is successful and what
happens next step well actually next
step is going to be a probably a much
bigger faith desire with much more
patient and this process needs to be
available because otherwise it's not
going to be possible to process with the
same protocol a bigger number of patient
but with the prodigy you can just easily
add more prodigy in the same facility
and then you expand the possibility and
the number of patients that you can
process at the same time but this is
applying also not only at one particular
facility but it can also be used with
centralized and the management and
production formulation of product so you
can envision a way in which a specific
site is developing the protocol and a
nice transfer in the technology and
protocol to different of sites where
they can manage in a much more local way
the production and delivery of different
intelligence products under a product in
general to the final patient and this
kind of cut down was the logistic
problem due to long distance transport
of material and the logical that is
usually a huge problem so now that we
overview a little bit the therapy and
the difficult in therapy I will show you
some of the optimize processes for the C
cellular products the duration
I will start with a small overview for
the three different prostitution and
then we will dive into the specific one
so with the clinic system you can
actually and kept the dendritic cells
for reducing salary back teens from all
different sources that we discussed
previously so you can start with cd14
monocytes or you can get a primary
dendritic cells and then there is also
the possibility to either they didn't
return for city healthy for positive
progenitor cells so in general for the
production of DC vaccine we need to go
through a few steps so you need first of
all to prepare the starting materials
from the local authorities in general
and then you need resolutions that one
differentiation is needed that and then
you pass to the antigen loading and
mahmoud motivational activation of the
dendritic cells to them prepare the
final product the for example this is
the typical protocol for this before
teaming aside resident Riddick term so
you start from disparities you isolated
the first in cell and then you
differentiate them culture by
cultivating them with gm-csf and is for
and then you mature them to then range
histamine patient so in this slide you
can see little bit more details about
how this product works so in the prodigy
you can use our thing about these our
achieving set to process specific
patient material and then you can reach
them on side you can differentiate them
with our
JMP cytokines and media and then you can
finally mature them and load them with
activators for example and then we also
offer only solution to characterize and
analyze the cell product at different
stages of the production process so as I
was saying I mean getting the cells is
not only part of it we also need sounds
that are active in functional and here
you can see how the isolation of the
monocytes from the lava resists with our
system is giving really great results
not only in terms of purity but also
variability and moreover you can also
notice that this is a very robust system
that is providing always very high
standard results so these help in
definitely producing cellular products
you can be commercialized and then can
be also study in details for the various
functional properties of this cell so in
the next slide we could show the mature
monastery regenerative cells isolated
with the prodigy retain their
functionality so in the bottom left you
can see our they mature in the result
can uptake 50 doctrine
molecules that indicate our every doubt
for advertising specific activities
while these activities obviously absent
partially in the mature and moody
monocytes as well and as another video
out you can also see how the phenotype
change from the monocytes with a
maturity the mature modest ease in time
considering the different expression
marker in this case we should OCD 206
density 209 and moreover for the mature
individuals we can show that the and the
functionality distance is completely
retained in the bottom right corner you
can see the virtual or the maturation in
the type from the yes the middle mature
phenotype of distance
considering different activation marker
and also the lack of expression cd14
that is lost during the differentiation
process in moderation and we could also
show the details behaviors and Hritik
cells that have been physiologically
activated and in fact they respond to
cr7 to migrate to the lymph node
technically speaking and we also can see
how the capacity with these cells to
stimulate these zones is written when
you load them with the particular
antigen and you stimulate them and
differentiate them following our
protocol we also wanted to show that
these the melissa generated with
economic strategy are able to produce
direct world in a morphological setting
and in this case we use the default
ligand and the cell lines expressing
reporting under recapitulate the
encounter of a dendritic cells with a
t-cell
inflammatory information environment and
as you can see that individuals readily
Express il-12 by not il-10 upon
encounter decisions
so these all rapidly fully functional
monitor drive and it excels they can be
used for investigation on the value of
these as a tool in DC vaccination so one
step of the process is the antigen
loading of the dendritic cells and this
is a very critical point so there are
different techniques and different tools
that you can use for the loading the
majority of the studies so far as used
protein and we provide the 50 billion
peptide tool for these we provide not
only research gradable approach and P
grade activator can be used for your
clinical mechanical research particular
other group system utilizes for these we
have particularly good instrument the
gentle max together that is very easy to
use and benchtop instrument can be very
helpful in the generation of tumor
lighted for your experiment not only for
this situation the third but also for
the tumor lysis preparation and finally
there are other group that use a marine
a little bit more coming up in the
individual as well and we recently
released the ellipse operator that can
be added to the prodigy and allow the
electrician to clinical scale of
cellular products so we tested different
ways of loading the dendritic cells or
the modesty in particular and you can
see as a small overview of four
different what three different
loading one is the non loaded modesty
control in the left and left side and
then you can see how the sounds loaded
with the specific PP 65 either protein
or mRNA is able to activate and in this
case is not usually this expression of
telomere expression so it's the terminal
staining that shows that the Pistons are
activated and they expand and you can
see how the antigen specific pieces are
expanded a response to the BP 65 protein
loaded on the dendritic cells and you
can also see that there is not a huge
difference between the different loading
strategies so we provide kind of
resolution for all of them and it's
really up to the researcher them to
decide which one suits best the kind of
antigen they are investigating so the
project is not only machine that is in
our in our kind of marketing material it
is already out there that is using
different trials at the moment the first
one of the first trial that is testing
the modesty generated prodigy is this
trial that is addressing liver cancer
from the reversible Birmingham and here
you can see what our researchers are
using the project says about the
productivity of the derivative saving
considerable hands-on time and it's
being relatively simple to scale out as
I was pointing out before so you can see
how the prodigy really help in designing
the dendritic cell based therapy and
outer skeleton
okay these therapy is going to be
successful
so having overview a little bit the
modesty process let's pass to the primal
intellect and so in this case you have
the climax LP BDC process and with this
process you can isolate both diplomacy
toyed and m11 lytic cells and then put
them together in a final cellular
product that is going to be then tested
as the result action so again these use
the prodigy as the platform there is the
first step of depletion for cd14
incident in positive cells this is
because a CD one see the market for my
loading results and that we using the
system is expressing visions and the
3:14 because it has been published
recently that there is a suppressive
separation of myeloid cells that do
express the protein that might hinder
the thickest II of dendritic cell
vaccine then we reach for the Malloy
destroyed in with Excel and finally we
load the antigen and activate the
dendritic cells before finalizing the
cell product let's see a little bit more
about this process so the end result of
a single be reversed sub cells in human
blood and they are very difficult to
characterize because that Malloy itself
they do express a lot of different
marker but not a specific quantities
like lineage marker so in this case we
develop a very useful panel of
antibodies we kind of exploited our
special affinity antibodies that provide
a much less background and as you can
see here this panel allows for the
characterization of all the different
subsets of human dendritic cells from
peripheral blood so in this experiment
we get it out as
we get it on city 14 but it sells and
viable cells and then we analyze them
with a different antibody that you can
see in the panel and these easily
discriminate all the different
separation of dendritic cells data
relevant for the product processing the
the BDC process allows for a very robust
and I a pure arrangement of blood and
excels both the serum disease as you can
see in this slide we reach really high
purity and the viability of the cells is
very high as well similar similar in a
way to what one Shalford even site
arrived in Greece exams and when it
comes to functionality as functional is
very important for the daenerys vaccine
I wouldn't the ER Rd both the myeloid
and a certain critics and respond to
different stimuli and you can note that
the best stimulus for P disease not
surprisingly the CPG PMP that we
recently released in the market this is
a two receptor agonist photos after nine
that is one of the strongest immunity
for further study and exams surprisingly
you can also see an activation of the
different visual markers studied in the
melodeon critic cells in response to
this region usually male dendritic cells
do not respond to the receptor 9 but
recent evidence in the literature has
shown kind of an activating or a chorus
activation loop between the Prados 13
riddick cells and model dendritic cells
and it is suggested that the activation
represents a dendritic cells in respond
in response to threat after nine
regulate the expression of the receptor
9
it excels that at that point respond as
well so Yolanda reveals that she's using
the president using the plasma Tori and
my lord and it excels in clinical trials
decided to put them together and see if
she could improve the efficacy of the
cellular product in a trial for the mind
disease that she's running at the moment
and then we also were able to show that
the tide loaded blood genetic cells can
induce activation of antigen specific
t-cells here you can see a lamellar done
between the delicious loaded and t-cells
and in this case we'll use wt1 as a
motivator so we are not expecting 12 end
of the competition and the PP 65
effective 800 because we are using the
CMV positive material so we knew that
some clones of t-cells would have being
there to respond and as you can see when
we test the cd8 positive T cells we can
readily see an additional secretion of
TNF alpha theorem gamma only in the PP
65 bottom panel that suggests that this
activation is antigen specific and
different media and then we also went on
and wanted to really prove that this
proliferation that is beta can also
induce proliferation of T cells and you
can see how with cell trace pilot we
could test the effect of end results
loaded on cd8 positive cells and how
these loaded enriched cells can
in an antigen specific manner again in
this proliferation of the t-cells and on
the right side of the slide we could
even prove further this proliferation is
antigen specific by staining with the
thermal 5065 and you can see that only
the proliferating T cells are the one
that test positive for the attacker
maintaining so we saw out there are
three different subject of belgian
resistance and lately
lots of the literature is focusing the
spotlight leader on the 341 positive
dendritic cells this is because that a
unique capacity to to ice to to cross
present antigen especially tumor antigen
a necrotic an antigen and so it's
probably one of the best target for the
development of cellular therapeutic
approach unfortunately though they're
also the most rare of the subsets of the
militant and it's very difficult to
isolate them but finally we started we
were approached by the pro crop
consortium that i asked us to be part of
this project and so we started a
collaborative european project entitled
professional climbing over m prostate
cancer and we are part of this
consortium as developer for the
isolation of the cities and refer to on
position riddick cells and there you can
see how we already managed to isolate
the c-141 from an experienced product
with our team uh strategy p 141 process
and further we were also already able to
show that these dendritic cells maintain
the functionality similar to water our
ability and the cd14 post internal
monitoring the big cells and they can be
stimulated at a similar distance to
produce interferon gamma in this case as
a result and when they are loaded with
the PP 6550 Vater and simulated policy
so here I show we were able to show that
we can not only either ladies super rare
and the big cells from human material
but that distance we can also their
activity and of the divide ability so
this this means that it might be
feasible to exploit them as therapeutic
tools or development of strata tools so
finally let's see what we discussed
today and so we show how different
individual subsets can be exploited to
investigate new and effective vaccine
strategies for future clinical
applications going to the different
subsets then we show a more standardized
transferable and scalable technology now
enable the optimization of protocols and
the processing and management of
cellular product in this case we spoke
about our clinics prodigy and our
research and GMP grade reagent and
ancillary products that are all really
important for the development of a lot
product that can be commercialized and
finally we also show how the the
cellular product at a huge potential to
become a critical component of
multifactorial multifactorial approaches
and are already under intensive study
their safety profile has been already
proven as also a it has been proven the
immunogenicity of
these approaches so in the end we can
see our new avenues of country
vaccination using functionally
specialized in the digital jobs that are
not possible and we kind of
so out there all of the individuals that
a strong argument might be instrumental
for the future development of preventive
cancer vaccines in fact in the
literature recently it has been shown in
in mouse models that the trickiest
vaccines are also able to induce
prevention of cancer development and in
this case that today that develop also
cancer vaccine that exploit combination
of immortality and other treatment
options so we did living to you the next
five five minutes for Q&A and MJ will
answer to all the questions but feel
free to contact me or our mass tech
support or tech support for any more
detailed excellent presentation dr. John
akin thank you dr. Melandri thanks for
bringing that information to us before
we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll get to as many as we can dr.
Joan ik and dr. Mel and Ray will answer
your questions in the Q&A first question
is how comparable is the yield of the
two processes considering the low
frequency of the bbc's and do you get
enough cells for treatments so also
welcome from my side everybody so the
numbers of dendritic cells have been
considered in the past to be a critical
factor that might hinder the development
of dendritic cell based therapies and in
fact this was one of the main reasons
why people started developing even
further into Excel based vaccines from
monocytes so one of the optic critical
points was to reach high numbers of
dendritic cells or vaccination
and this was also reason why why at
least in the past people didn't use
blood bone or blood derived and RIT
accepted purpose
on the other hand there was no tools in
the past for clinical grade isolation of
the start and so regarding the numbers
we know that most of the clinicians or
investigators I use or aiming for
getting about two to four times to the
eighth often the dendritic cells for
vaccinations protocols and from our
collaboration with with Yolanda debris
slit and now in the consulship proko
convulsion in collaboration with George
Cukor's ignite in my Lego until under
degrees we know that at least using the
process for blood for the isolation of
blood androids except we may end up with
more than one x to the 10 to the eighth
of dendritic cells in the final
preparation so the number is not so low
as as we could maybe expect so this is
quite quite a high number already and of
course using this cells one of the
critical points might be also the route
of administration and we all know that
by injecting cells in the periphery like
into the dermis
lots of the cells get lost in the tissue
and don't migrate to the lymph nodes and
to solve this problems we aimed for
internodal inductor injections and at
least in the first studies we
conducted by by Yolanda the leaflet we
could already see that as few as six
million self-injection were worth
sufficient to induce antigen-specific
decent responses so it's it's of course
a numbers game at certain point but on
the other hand it's also a metal fusing
the right cells and injecting them to
the right spot what is the rationale
behind the choice of magnetic separation
over a different method for the DC
cellular product preparation what it's
it's kind of that it's called to
religion and the question what was the
best way to to isolate this and there
are a few a few techniques in the field
isolating not maybe not dendritic cells
but at least the progenitors and then I
think we are talking to you about the
monocytes so for for the isolation of
monocytes the alteration can be used or
some people also use cell adhesion as
monetised adhere to the plastic surfaces
upon taking them out and so on the other
hand if we talk about generation of of
dendritic cell product for for
vaccination one of the main issues is
the reproducibility and and and the
quality of the product you get and only
using the magnetic cell separation is
possible to obtain the high quality and
the high purity of the starting material
which are monocytes and we all know that
monocytes acquired homology a
heterogeneous population consisting of
the cd14 positive cd16 negatives
classical model monocytes and as well
expressing cd16 a/c receptor and some
differentiation stages in in between but
all might have an hour or in described
in the literature to have different
functional functions so in terms of
getting a reproducible product and also
to start with well-defined starting
material it is really important to to
obtain a pure population of cells
regarding the blood and route itself
very basically no no alternatives in the
market to isolate and so also an acid
assess also so rare in the starting
population it's really difficult to get
them using different ways as the
magnetic separation so I think it's it
will be a controversial in the future
for assignment degree but at least as
Melanie we believe that the magnetic
cell sorting is the only way to to
provide pure starting populations for
for this kind of vaccine generation BC
therapy has been around a while now why
should we focus on that instead of
checkpoint inhibitors so the checkpoint
inhibitors have been proven in the in
the last few years to be very effective
in a number of indications and however
they on the one hand they of course
target
target pieces that are already present
in the patient so there are already
studies showing that there is a strong
correlation between the presence of
tumor infiltrating T cells and there is
also a correlation with it with the
mutational load of the given tumor and
even looking in in one particular
indication there are subgroups of
patients that I will respond to this
type of treatment or not and it has been
shown that the presence of tumor
reactive T cells is in a critical
critical point of that so I think in the
field already law
lots of investigators recognized that
the future therapies won't be the more
therapies but rather combinatory
therapies that combine different
treatments and then the success are very
powerful tool to complement the immune
response and also to provide tumor
active T cells in the body that then in
the second step and this might for sure
make a lot of sense
it could be combined with the checkpoint
inhibitors that in turn unblock or
prevent the suppression of the tumor
active T cells in the tumor tissue how
do you choose the antigen to load on the
PC and what about the method of loading
so the choice off of the antigen is it's
also not known on the simple question so
on the one hand there is a lot of
literature in the field
that points to the expression of
different entity to my associated
antigens and different indications and I
think all of us making use of this of
this knowledge by by choosing this
antigens on the other hand in the last
year's there were all of new antigens
appear to be to be a awesome important
point so now not only the tumor
associated antigens play a player or
important for induction of costume or
specific immune responses but the neo
antigens may also be very important
the special thing about or yeah about
the new antigens is that these antigens
are patient specific and they require
and so that the identification
production of the advantages requires
the development of new processes that
provide these antigens in a needed
quality and in a short time so these are
challenges that we are facing
you forgot to this kind of antigens on
the other hand the the type of the
antigen whether we use the protein
peptide or mRNA is also an important
factor that might be critical peptides
are used quite broadly in this kind of
applications however they require the
knowledge about sequence of the peptide
into the context of the given MHC of the
patient which is not always known so
it's not always available this
information on the other hand using mRNA
we can overcome this issue as the
dendritic cell itself can
[Music]
generate the peptides that are loaded on
the NHC also this approach has some
limitations one of the limitations might
be that tumors can also alter the
function of the proteasome that might
lead to a different set of peptides that
are presented by the tumor cell so in
the end it could of course also be that
the peptide set generated by the non
with itself is at least not identical
with the path I said that is produced by
the medici matzoh the first option is to
use the whole protein or tumor lysis
this is at least the tremulous have the
advantage that they by definition
contain all the tumor specific antigens
and on the other hand this protein
antigens need to be taken up added and
with excels and process and as we heard
already in the today's presentation
not all dendritic cells are specialized
in cross presenting these antigens so we
hope that using the cross presenting
subset which is 3 141 or x01 positive we
might find or we might use the right
subtype of them to take cells for tumor
vaccination and our goal however is to
to develop certain points a process that
provides all for three subsets from
blood in combination so so we can make
use of logistic effects between the
functions of the given substance thank
you if we didn't get your question we
will follow up with you via email I
would like to once again thank dr. Joe
Nick for his presentation do you have
any final comments
no we all first hope that this
presentation was interesting to you and
if you have any questions please contact
us via email or on RIT now yes well
thank you again I would also like to
thank our sponsor Milton E biotechs for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the see e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June 2018 you'll receive
an email from us learning you when it's
available on-demand and posted on lab
routes calm you're welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we will see you next time